pascal de l'image chef économiste
d'harwell management auteur du livre à
capitalisme et technologies les liaisons
dangereuses aux éditions forme
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec moi en
direct sur arte france alors encore une
chance ou pas de voir un accord ce soir
ou dans la nuit
il y à il ya une chance de voir un
accord effectivement parce que il y a
d'abord de bonnes raisons d'y croire la
première c'est que nous avons déjà
quelque part réussi à faire un peut
infléchir l'allemagne sur cette position
de la mutualisation de la dette en
particulier
et puis ensuite il y à une situation de
crise économique
malheureusement qui cette fois ci oblige
oblige l'europe à ne pas échouer et donc
c'est presque la dernière chance pour
construire une europe fédérale donc
quelque part ces deux raisons qui font
qu'il n'est qu' on ne peut qu'espérer et
ce serait vraiment très regrettable pour
l'europe
si cette fois ci elle ne prenait pas le
virage comme ça a été le cas notamment
dans la crise de la dette grecque par
exemple le pire scénario
ce serait quoi finalement s'il n'y a pas
d'accord au terme de cette troisième
journée de négociation à bruxelles est
ce qu'on aura un autre sommet est ce que
il faut tout revoir à 0 là si ce qui se
passe c'est qu'on va retomber dans des
accords sur des montants plus faibles
parce que là on a des montants
considérables 750 milliards c'est
l'occasion de d'initier un fédéralisme
européen donc si c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui on va retomber sur des
négociations est d accord qu on connaît
maintenant depuis des années dont
d'ailleurs il va être partie des
européens à placer et puis surtout ça va
être encore une fois des pays je dirais
comme la france l'allemagne bref qui
sont extrêmement bien notée par les
agences de notation qui vont pouvoir se
développer
emprunter à des taux extrêmement
intéressant et donc finalement c'est le
risque de faire prolonger d'une certaine
façon une europe à deux vitesses qui
existent déjà depuis un certain temps
aujourd'hui c'est un effort de
solidarité
que l'on demande l'allemagne fait un
premier pas et il y à une crise
sanitaire avec des conséquences
économiques graves qui font finalement
que l'europe ne peut pas cette fois ci
passer à côté de l'histoire
c'est peut-être sa dernière chance
peut-être est en tout cas sa dernière
chance d'aller vers quelque chose d'un
peu plus fédérale et de commencer à
construire une véritable europe sur la
base de projets qui nous prenait
numérique et sociale avec des ressources
communes existent à défaut de d'aboutir
à un accord finalement ces négociations
est ce qu elles ne sont pas le reflet
faisait allusion à 2-2 europe
qu'est-ce qui s'affrontent qui est une
europe divisée
une europe solidaire et l'europe non
solidaire alors en fait c'est un peu il
ya 2 il ya deux problèmes le premier
aussi un problème lié au fait que les
décisions sont prises à l'unanimité donc
si les pays bas refusent une dette
commune et bien les décisions sont pas
prises la façon dont sont nous les
décisions sont prises au sein de l'union
européenne en termes démocratique
finalement une haine le principe de
l'unanimité complique énormément les
choses là on n'est pas dans des
principes de majorité donc ça c'est un
premier point
le deuxième point c'est que aujourd'hui
les fruits beau en fait un bon pays bas
autriche et danemark suède danemark
suède en dehors de la zone euro donc
ceux qui sont les plus réfractaires au
principe d'un plan de relance avec une
dette mutualisée commune avec des
ressources communes pose quand même des
conditions qui sont pas mis plus
aberrantes un qui est celle de pouvoir
contrôler les fonds qui est celle de
pouvoir s'assurer le plein développement
démocratique des états voilà il ya quand
même des choses qui sont pas
complètement incohérente et puis aussi
le fait qu'il souhaite qu'une part de
prêts soit c'est à dire de comment dire
d'investissement qui puisse être
remboursée
la part des prêts soit plus élevé que la
part des subventionnements en tout cas
par rapport à ce qui existe aujourd'hui
donc
voilà c'est juste quelque part ce qu'ils
demandent c'est de responsabiliser un
tout petit peu davantage le pays du sud
si on peut le dire de cette façon la
façon peu simple sur un véritable
engagement totalement transparent sur
les fonts finalement qui sont qui seront
alloués par des pays qui quelque part
aussi un peu mieux gérer cette crise que
les autres et donc ils ont aussi un
droit de parole national par rapport à
ces questions là certains pays d'un
repère non la hongrie et voit d'un très
mauvais oeil ces conditionnalités
imposées a frappé l'est du sud
alors ils sont effectivement tous types
à part je dirais mais effectivement là
la vraie question c'est c'est que on
peut pas continuer un peu ce qu'on avait
fait à l'époque de la crise des grecs et
qu'il faut trouver un juste équilibre
entre le contrôle des fonds par des
réformes qui sont finalement très
souvent des réformes très proche de
politiques d'austérité dont les citoyens
de passer finalement
et puis en même temps ne pas aller dans
l'autre extrême qui consiste à ne pas
regarder un peu ce qu'ils sont ce qui se
fait en matière de voile à deux c'est
quand même 750 milliards alors la
croissance économique devienne
européenne et 15 milliards donc ça fait
après 5% s'est pas non plus et des
montants importants valeur absolue mais
il faut aussi quand même relativiser
cela bref pour résumer je dirais
vraiment continuer dans cet équilibre
entre austérité et croissance est
quelque part l'endroit où raison aussi
comme les frigos de demander des
contreparties en regard de cela merci
beaucoup à vous pascal de lima d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chef économiste d'harwell
management et auteur de capitalisme à et
technologies les liaisons dangereuses
aux éditions forme merci à vous et bonne
soirée